he is none other than Mike Florio how
are you Michael hey rich I already felt
hanging in there I hope you had a good
Father's Day weekend yep same to you
fantastic thank you for a greatly
appreciated so is dad gonna put his
signature on that dumb piece of paper
today yeah it sure sounds that way and
it's kind of a surprise because he had
been so dug in and the impression that
we've gotten is he wants his long-term
contract by July 15 and if they don't
give it to him he's potentially going to
stay away from training camp and
preseason but the bottom line his
quarterbacks got to be ready to go and
in his mind this is a contract year just
like last year was last year was a
contract year for two million this
year's a contract year for 31.4 million
but it's still a contract year and he
needs to have a good year he's got a new
coach he's got a new approach he's got a
new everything that he's got to get up
to speed with now a lot of same
teammates obviously see my offensive
coordinator but he needs to be ready to
go he's not plug-and-play like a living
on bail in 2017 he's the guy who needs
to be there and it also takes off the
table the very very very slim
possibility that the Cowboys would
change in their mind about rescinding a
franchise tender and making him a free
agent at a time when everyone's depth
chart is set and everyone's budgets been
turned upside down so why hasn't there
been a deal is it just a back-end fourth
fifth year is it covert 19 messing
potentially with future caps and the
Cowboys trying to figure out what that
might be before they sign him what do
you think this is well the impediment
rich is that it's a deadline driven
business and the deadline is July 15th
right and if anybody moves toward their
bottom line now what happens is you're
gonna get squeezed off of it when it
comes time to figure out exactly how
much you know you're gonna pay and yes
here's my bottom line well your bottom
line today is gonna become your bottom
line plus something else on July 14 so
that's part of it but you know here's
what it comes down to Jack's got thirty
one point four million in hand once he
signs the franchise tender next year
he's in line for a 20 percent raise if
they tagged him again that's thirty
seven point six eight million at sixty
nine point oh eight million combined for
two years plus the year three what do
you do
transition tag 45 million franchise tag
54 million for one year or let him walk
away like Kirk Cousins
in Washington from a couple of years ago
what do you do and from tax perspective
they need to offer him something that
will cause him to say I'll trade in this
bird in the hand for whatever it is that
you're offering me and and only doc
knows what what the offer is going to be
to require him to say okay I'll give up
my chance to go year-to-year and make
nearly seventy million and potentially
force my way to free agency in just two
years so he the cousins route the Kirk
Cousins path to nine figures in the bank
basically is what we're saying exactly
and the open market I mean look you know
people get mad at DAC for not taking
whatever the Cowboys want to pay him but
the Cowboys have taken full advantage of
all rights they have under the CBI they
paid him for four years as a fourth
round draft pick and last year he made
two million dollars they didn't give him
an extension that he found acceptable he
played that year with the injury risk
and now he's in a spot where they've
chosen to apply the franchise tag
they've chosen to apply the exclusive
level of the franchise tag at thirty-one
point four million dollars five or four
million more than what the non exclusive
level would have been and so now he has
rights in the face of that and his
biggest right at this point is to say
I'll take thirty one point for now I'll
take thirty seven point six eight next
year and then you're going to have to
make one hell of a decision in 2022 Mike
Florio here on the Rich Eisen show why
does Jerry Jones always do this late
with everybody what's what's the well
here's what I think I think that Jerry
believes that when the time comes to
throw his arm around a guy and remember
this bubbled up last year with the ZQ
Elliott Stern it was talk of how they
did it with Dez Bryant how they'll try
to negotiate directly with the player
even though they're not supposed to
negotiate directly with a player who's
represented by an NFL PA certified agent
it happens and I think they believe that
you know at the appropriate time they're
gonna be get back to take less than what
he otherwise is entitled to and you know
they got that with Tony Romo who was
undrafted who wasn't supposed to be in
the NFL at all he took less than maybe
he could have gotten if he had played it
out and I think they've been stunned big
picture by the fact that doc didn't take
whatever they offered last year before
he entered the last year
you know there's a Joe Flacco vibe to
all of this I mean flat I mean even
though Flacco won the Super Bowl and was
the MVP and and was able to leverage
that into the biggest contract ever
signed by any quarterback at the time
but he bet on himself he said no thanks
to the offer that the Ravens made in
August of 2012 and and and he won and
even though the Cowboys were eight eight
last year
dak did the same thing and dak won and
here he is with 31 point four million in
hand which is a nice raise over the two
million he made last year Mike Florio
here on the Rich Eisen show from Pro
Football Talk and NBC Sports asking a
poll question Chris this is as we he
traffics in the same world as sports
time Mike I you were on the line when we
were hashing this out which QB would you
rather have this coming season dak Tyler
Murray Kirk Cousins Carson Wentz for
this season for one season only mmm-hmm
I'd rather have Kyler Murray and here's
why and I heard you guys talking about
this and this is something that I've
said in 2017 we saw Carson Wentz in his
second year take the NFL by storm until
he suffered the ACL injury against the
Rams in December 2018 Patrick mahomes in
his second year took the NFL by storm
2019 Lamar Jackson in his second year
took the NFL by storm
I think caller Murray's gonna be that
guy this year and I know it's a
difficult division but I guess if you
give me the chance to get him out of the
NFC West he's even more attractive if
you get him in any other division in the
league he's the guy I wanted my
quarterback because I think he's going
to explode this year I agree with you I
totally agree with you I'm and it's
amazing the conversation should he play
where should he go to baseball like that
was actually a real conversation that
was had I mean that's the thing you know
we've seen guys who have had the ability
maybe to make it in another sport and be
really good in one this guy had the
potential to be really good in two
different sports and he's any shorter
than me which makes me like him even
more somebody in the sport is shorter
than me it's wonderful and he's got a
quarterback coach situation where
they're plugged in and DeAndre Hopkins
being added to
that makes you know I'm I'm thinking
there's gonna be a very large Arizona
bandwagon as though as the league year
gets closer and in that front I guess we
should turn to that conversation right
now Mike what are you hearing about the
NFL and the conversations about the 2020
season is we're sitting here right now
on the on the backside of the longest
day of the year well you know it's funny
rich if we pay attention to what's out
there publicly there's enough little
pieces that you can string together the
popcorn and come to the conclusion
that's going to be very difficult to
play NFL football this year when we see
that X number of Clemson players have
tested positive in LSU and there's an
outbreak here and they shut down this
program and they've shut down that
program and then also I don't feel like
there's a true consensus yet between the
league in the Union as to what they're
agreeing to and the clock is ticking on
reaching an agreement on what's going to
happen in training camp and beyond but I
circled back with someone who told me in
early May that there is an extremely
small chance there won't be an NFL
season this year and I felt compelled to
circle back because based on everything
that had happened last week I'm thinking
man this just doesn't this doesn't look
as promising as I thought it was
supposed to look but I was told the
league is still highly optimistic the
games will be played there's less
optimism that fans will be in the stands
then there wasn't early May but the bulk
of the money comes from televising the
games and they continue to be very
optimistic one of the issues is that
they believe very strongly that when
you're on a football field when you're
not in a confined space the droplets
don't linger the way that they do
indoors and the speculation is the
outbreak at Clemson the 23 positives
probably a weight room thing where you
got the heavy air you got guys exhaling
you got other guys right there and their
eyes and their noses can be invaded by
the droplets and I think that that is
the difference so the NFL planning very
extreme measures to keep people apart
indoors and then when we cross the
water's edge to the football field even
though there's no way to socially
distance and play football like Sean
McVeigh said last week rightly so
there's less of a concern of infection
because it's either outdoors or under a
giant roof where those droplets can
dissipate in a way that they can't
inside so it's interesting how you
mentioned Mike Florio here on the Rich
Eisen show it's interesting how you
mentioned that revenue is generated by
the showing of the game's not the
showing up to the games a complete
opposite from what it sounds like from
Major League Baseball and the continuing
argument that he that it has with its
Players Association right now so what
what might be between now and the
beginning of a season be part of the
conversation between the NFL and its
Players Association that throws some
sort of a speed bump into the plan of
having a season what are you saying is
there anything there was an idea slow
out now look if they're completely wrong
about how the virus operates and there's
outbreak after outbreak in training
camps and they just don't have the
bodies that can come in and take the
places of the players and this is
different from the replacements in 1987
during the strike because you know if
you've got half of your starting lineup
wiped out because they've tested
positive even if they're asymptomatic
they're quarantined for two or three
weeks you you go get a left guard who's
been sitting on the couch eating pork
rinds and watching bowling and he's the
only guy out there and you put him next
to your left tackle who you're paying 17
million dollars a year to you're putting
that left tackle at risk if you just
bring this guy in out of nowhere and one
thing I've been saying rich is they need
to consider doing what the XFL did with
a ninth team of guys who were not
attached to any one team but they were
kept in shape they were coached they
were practicing and they were ready to
go and the NFL most needs to have two
three or four of those rosters out there
if there is an outbreak it's not just
like call a guy up and get him in here
regardless of what kind of shape you may
be in it's we have guys who are ready to
plug in and they're not going to
compromise the health of the guys next
to him so that's the kind of thing that
can make it fall apart and then from the
leak in the union standpoint if the
league tries to get money back from the
players and the players dig in and say
no that could create an impasse I don't
think it's going to get to that point
though I think at the end of the day
they'll work out the money I think at
the end of the day the players have no
obligation to say any
thing of them we have our contracts for
this year next year is where the
conversation gets interesting as to what
the salary cap will be in light of what
the impact on the cap is as a result of
this year's reduced revenue yeah I mean
again and that's that kind of brings us
back full circle of the duck Prescott
conversation because if the Cowboys just
say alright plan the franchise tag maybe
they're hoping by July 15th there'll be
a better idea if there is a deal about
how to make sure the 21 and the 22 and
23 cap is handled so all the teams that
planned out their contracts expecting a
rising cap they don't get totally
hamstrung and screwed quite honestly so
we'll see how that all works out is
there anything else that's going on in
the NFL that that is taking up so much
of the oxygen is it what's going on off
the field right now Mike I mean what
what what do we discuss and at what
point will we find out do you think a
date certain by which people are gonna
be reporting I think that we'll know at
some point not long after the fourth of
July and you know it's time for some
agreements to be reached between the
league and the union it's time for the
players to understand what's going to be
expected of them and I've heard talk of
the possibility of giving players a
chance to opt out if they're just not
comfortable this year for whatever
reason if they're not comfortable being
in that environment they don't want to
potentially infect family members or
they have prior health conditions like a
Patrick Peterson 2 diabetes James Conner
who fought cancer there may be guys who
say I don't want to do this and maybe
coaches you say I don't want to do it
and I think there's gonna be an
allowance for those people who aren't
comfortable going forward in this
climate that's going to be part of it
but but we're getting closer and closer
to rich five six weeks away well if
they're gonna open training camp on time
some agreements need to be made and
announced and and I think that they need
to let the rest of us know that you know
if there is a high degree of optimism
behind the curtain that the season is
going to go forward we need to start
seeing some of the fruits of that so we
can all we can all say yes there will be
football this year instead of worrying
about it for the next three months I'm
just wondering again Mike that if is
there a possibility I mean now that the
NBA has created their bubble world we're
hearing about the ability to you know
turn the magic ring that that people who
go and get their passports to fun and
Disneyworld to use to open up their
doors of their hotel rooms to actually
add a component to it that can give you
an idea if you've got a symptom for
kovat 19:00 I'm just wondering if the
NFL they have to with all their money
and influence and and and I guess the
the amount of time that they've had have
run up some sort of technology that
we're unaware of that maybe even the NBA
could give a test run in in July to
allow for better testing better tracing
better everything to to allow for a
season to happen I'm just wondering are
you here anything about that oh yeah and
and and look I was told back in early
May and this was the reason why I was
told that there's an extremely small
chance that the season won't happen
there's a belief that by August and
September
there will be rapid response testing
reliable testing accurate testing and
I've always envisioned rich when you're
talking about the petri dish that is an
NFL locker room now there is a way to
socially distance but once you're in the
building and the virus is in the
building that's a problem once you're on
the field and the virus is on the field
that's a problem and I've always
envisioned that there would be basically
an airlock where you go in you take a
test whether it's a saliva test or a
finger prick and five minutes later you
know whether or not you're positive and
if you're negative you go in if you're
positive you get put in quarantine and
that person never gets through and I
think the duties of the communities
includes testing them on the way out as
well so you don't have someone who was
negative when they walked in there
positive walking out you're sending them
back out to the community without
knowing that they're positive and I
would like to believe that the testing
will be so prevalent by August or
September that they'll be able to do
that and test them every day I've heard
other things suggesting they're not
going to test them every day and I look
at that and I say how can you how can
you not test every day and I know
there's practicalities involved and
expenses involved but I think that's one
of the key components if you're gonna
have guys out on the football field
sweating and bleeding and you know
breathing over each other for three
hours at a time you need to be certain
that anybody who has access to that
space is negative all right what else
what's going on in your world you got
your pod right you got the Daily Show
you got a VL working keep cranking we
keep cranking and we keep looking for
what's next and even though there isn't
a whole lot of football news because we
didn't have an off season program you
know we watch what's an accident watch
this after July 15 the next guy to watch
it - Sean Watson and I'm told that he
wants a three year extension on the two
years that he has left with the Texans
and that he's likely to get it they gave
lerm counsel a three-year extension
usually teams don't do extensions that's
short so I think the dominoes are gonna
go Prescott then Watson then mahomes and
even if Prescott doesn't do a deal I
think Watson wants a wait to see what
Prescott does because I think he's gonna
take Prescott Steele and say give me
that plus X on top of it and then
mahomes is gonna be the one that just
blows everyone out of the water and I
think that thing's coming before the
season starts you know what it would be
smart to do it it would be smart to do
it and that's why it would be smart for
the Joneses to figure it out with dak
now before a new ceiling is set that
becomes his floor so what are the
numbers you're hearing for for Watson in
mahomes then well I I think my homes you
know we've always heard 40 million
dollars or more per year now that
becomes complicated because when you
talk about 40 million in new money a
five year 200 million dollar extension
that gets added to is to existing years
and it ends up being a lot less than 40
million a year so there's different ways
to look at these deals but I think in
terms of new money it's going to be dak
around 35 Watson around 38 my home is
around 40 or maybe more and possibly
with my homes rich something that I've
been advocating for a while and that
different players have tried to get but
haven't been able to my homes needs to
have a set salary or a percentage of the
salary cap whichever is greater
so he's protected against explosions in
the cap that make his pay
relative to other quarterbacks relative
to other players seem less whether it's
18% 17% it's perfectly permissible under
the CBA
the teams have resisted
and if anybody's gonna get it it's
Patrick behind so you become an 18% er
you know that's what you're saying like
a 20% Wow Wow
Mike thanks to the time in this
situation is better being 18% of than 1%
I'm s
well it certainly put you in a different
bracket no doubt about that
thanks for the call Mike appreciate
spirit you got that's Mike Florio live
pro football talk hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here